Prof: Good morning.
Now today's topic is Weber's
theory of legal-rational
authority and his theory of
bureaucracy.
This is one of those
questions--those topics--Weber
is probably the best known for.
It's also a rather complicated
issue.
When we are saying
legal-rational authority,
we briefly refer to the rule of
law,
and we tend to associate in our
mind the rule of law with
liberal market economies and the
liberal democracies.
Well Weber has a very complex
argument about this.
Indeed, legal-rational
authority is the kind of system
of authority which is
predictable,
because there is an observable
law,
everybody is subordinated to,
which,
in fact, has the most--the
clearest elective affinity with
a market economy.
Nevertheless,
as we will see,
he will argue that--which is
very counterintuitive--that the
purest type of legal-rational
authority is bureaucracy;
and this is usually what we
don't have in our mind when we
are thinking about a market
economy, that it is
bureaucratic.
So we have to deal with Weber's
interesting claim that the
purest type of legal-rational
authority,
which goes together with a
market capitalist economy,
is actually bureaucracy.
It's also interesting that
Weber does not make an
assumption that bureaucracy,
legal-rational authority,
or capitalism necessarily goes
together with democracy.
How democracy fits into the
picture is rather problematic
for him.
Of course, we have to
appreciate that in Weber's--
when Weber was writing about
these issues,
somewhere between 1914 and
1920, I mean,
virtually none of the countries
in the world were liberal
democracies or universal
suffrage.
The political systems of the
world changed so much in the
last hundred years.
But he problematizes this
relationship;
and it's actually quite useful.
So this is the guideline for
today's lecture.
Again I start with the
definition of the ideal type,
the purest type of
legal-rational authority,
and then I try to dig into this
unusual but very influential
Weberian argument--
that bureaucracy,
in fact, is the purest type of
legal-rational authority.
And then I will look at various
kinds of limitations of the
exercise of bureaucratic
authority.
One is collegiality.
The other is functional
division of labor--
right?--the separation of
various branches of government,
which is a limitation on
bureaucracy,
and representation,
democracy, is a limitation on
government.
So you can see that he sees a
tension--right?--between
democracy, bureaucracy,
legal-rational authority and
capitalism.
They do not go as easily
together as usually we Americans
tend to think about this.
And then a couple of ideas
about his view about
democracies.
Okay, so let me start with what
is the pure type of
legal-rational authority.
And there are really two issues
we have to very briefly talk
about.
There are different ways how
laws and norms can be
established.
We're already beginning to feel
our way into the problem whether
the rule of law and democracy
are identical,
or, you know,
it can be democratic,
or does not have to be that
democratic.
And then the question is who
obeys what and whom,
under legal authority?
So and a bit about
legal-rational authority.
So the argument
is--right?--that there are
various ways how laws or norms
can be established.
And well he said,
legal authority rests on the
acceptance of the following
ideas.
Right?
Well, the norms,
he said, can be established by
agreement--that's what we
usually think when we think
about rule of law--or by
imposition;
it can be imposed on people.
Right?
And it can happen on the ground
of expediency.
It can happen because these are
the most useful laws and
therefore we either agree that
this is what we want to obey,
or there is an authority which
they impose on us.
Or it can be based on value
rationality.
It may not be that expedient,
may be not necessarily
immediately useful,
but on the basis of shared
values, or the values of those
who impose those laws--
and we tend to believe it--we
will--
this is the way how it will be
established.
And then, of course,
the legal system has to be
somewhat consistent--
this is important for the
predictability of the system--
and has to be intentionally
established.
Right?
This is not coming from
accident, but intentionally
established.
But the major point what I
wanted to make--right?--that
legal-rational authority,
in Weber's view,
can be actually an
authoritarian system.
Let's say Chile under Pinochet,
the later times,
after he
established--consolidated his
power;
earlier on it was a tyrannical
rule.
But later on,
Pinochet established a
legal-rational order,
though it was not democratic at
all.
Right?
It was operating with a legal
system which was imposed on
people.
And in history we have a number
of instances when we can say,
"This is country is a
country of law and order.
We know what the laws are;
we actually think the laws are
not unreasonable.
But it was imposed by some
power upon us."
Now the next question is who
obeys whom?
And well I don't want to dwell
on this so long.
This is quite clear.
You already are familiar with
this.
What is important--right?--the
person who is in authority,
who issues orders,
is himself subject to an
impersonal order.
So we are all subject to the
same order.
This is the essence of
legal-rational authority,
at least in the ideal type.
Right?
We know the exceptions to this.
We know that Berlusconi,
for instance,
in Italy, though Italy is
really a legal-rational
authority,
for a long time
managed--right?--to pass a
legislation which enabled him to
escape prosecution;
though he's probably involved
in a number of criminal
activities, but somehow he
managed to escape criminal
prosecution.
But that's the exception.
The rule is--right?--that even
the person who is highest in
charge is subject to the same
authority and has to obey the
law.
And this is again very obvious;
we already covered this,
the opposite,
the mirror image of it.
Right?
The members of the society of
obedience, to the superior,
not as an individual,
but to an impersonal order,
to the law as such.
That should be quite obvious.
Now so what are the major
characteristics of a system
which is based on legal-rational
order?
There is a continuous
rule-bound conduct.
It's again, I think,
does not call for too much
clarification.
It is continuously the same
rules.
The rules change slowly and
with a great deal of
difficulties,
as we can see how Congress is
struggling to pass a law about
health care reform.
It takes months or years before
an important new piece of
legislation gets into place.
And usually new pieces of
legislations,
in legal-rational authority,
are grandfathered.
Right?
If you pass a new law,
you change the rules of the
game, you usually grandfather
them;
those who entered the game
before the new law are still
under the rule of the old law.
We do that at the universities
all the time.
Right?
If, for instance,
the degree requirements do
change in a university,
almost always these degree
requirements are--
this new legislation is
grandfathered.
You know the terminology. Right?
It will not apply to people who
are already in the program.
It will only apply to people
who are entering the program.
Or one way of grandfathering
it, that we give people a
choice.
You know?
If you want to operate under
the new rule,
you can opt for the new rule;
or if you want to stay under
the old rule,
you can stay under old rule.
Only for those are the new
rules binding who are entering
the system now.
So that's very
important--right?--that it is
continuous and rule-bound.
And he also said in
legal-rational authority there
must be a very clear separation
of spheres of competence.
Right?
Who is competent to carry out
what?
And then you can always figure
out how you navigate in a
legal-rational order.
You will be told,
"Well, this is not my
table, you go somewhere
else."
So you go and you ask something
from the director of
undergraduate studies,
and the director of
undergraduate studies might say,
"Go and see the dean of
your residential college"--
right?--"because that is
the sphere of competence of the
residential college."
That's the way how
legal-rational order is supposed
to operate.
And the same,
occasionally the dean of
college will say,
"Well, you have to see
your sociology professor,
or your economics
professor."
Right?
You want to get transfer
credit, for instance,
for a summer course,
and then the dean of college
well said,
"It is the
department"--
be it political science or
economics or anthropology--
"they will be able to tell
whether this can be accepted as
an economics course at
Yale." Right?
And this also implies that
there is always a hierarchy and
a right to appeal.
This is--again,
you are very familiar with it.
You know exactly if you get a
grade from your discussion
section leader,
you can appeal to the professor
to say,
"Well, I don't think it's
a fair enough grade.
I deserve a better grade.
My section leader made an
error."
And if you are unhappy with the
response of the professor,
you go to the chair of the
department and appeal to the
chair.
There is a whole hierarchy of
appeal--right?--where you can
try to correct what you think is
not right.
So I think it's extremely
important that you know exactly
what is the chain of appeal and
how far you can go up.
Usually there is also some
specialized training which is
expected for people to occupy
certain positions.
So well discussion section
leaders will always be at least
graduate students;
usually, well,
people can teach their own
course once they were
passed--they are Ph.D.
students but all what they have
is a dissertation to finish,
or they must have their Ph.D.
Right?
So there is a specialized
training necessary to perform
certain functions,
as such.
And that's an interesting and
very complex idea--
right?--that the staff has to
be separated from the ownership
of means of production and
administration.
This is even more important for
Weber's argument.
Being separated--it's not that
easy to penetrate what he
exactly wants to say with this.
What does it mean that you do
not own the means of
administration?
It basically means that the
source of rules and laws are
outside of the administrator as
such.
If you want to have any change
in the rules,
there must be some procedure
which is beyond the person who
is administering that rules,
how the rules can be changed.
Right?
This in order--you have to
prevent unpredictability in the
system.
And that's why rules change all
the time.
But the fundamental principle
is that these rules should not
be allowed to be changed by the
person who
administers--right?--those
rules.
So just to give a very trivial
example,
once you got your syllabus and
the course requirement and what
kind of assignments you have to
deliver during the course in
order to get credit in this
course,
then well working out these
rules, a professor plays a role.
But we have to get approved by
the Courses and Curriculum
Committee, and then in a way we
are bound by those rules.
So on the way I could not
announce you today,
"Well I changed my mind
and there will be an unseen
final examination where you will
have to get a final
examination--
right?--and you will not know
what questions I will ask,
and I can ask any question for
the whole course."
Right?
If I would
change--right?--these rules
right now, you would have,
I'm sure, appeal against me,
against my decision.
Right?
I'm bound by rules.
So that means that I don't own
the means of administration.
Right?
I am
administering--right?--what is
in the syllabus.
Well there is a little leeway.
Right?
Occasionally I can give you an
extension, for instance,
if you come to me.
Therefore it's--there is a
little flexibility in the
system.
But fundamentally the course
should be taught as it is in the
syllabus, and the requirements
should be like it is in the
syllabus.
That's what it
means--right?--that you do not
own--
right?--the means of
administration,
unlike in traditional authority
where a feudal lord does have--
does own, appropriated,
some means of administration
from the monarch.
And a British or a French high
aristocracy could make rules;
not implement the rules,
but could make rules as well.
The unique feature of modern
legal-rational authority is that
this becomes an impersonal
process,
which is not done--there is a
separation between those who
implement the rules,
and there is a separate
procedure--right?--
how the rules are being
established.
Is that reasonably clear,
what ownership of means of
administration means?
As I pointed out,
it's a very Weberian idea.
Right?
For Marx--right?--the whole
issue is the ownership of means
of production.
For Weber this is everything
about the administrations-- the
means of administration.
Okay, now we come to this very
interesting Weberian theory of
the bureaucracy:
very interesting,
very controversial,
in many ways very
counterintuitive.
You may say it is false.
Well we will see.
That is a nice topic for
discussion sections.
And this is what I will go
through--a number of issues.
What is a bureaucracy?
Weber makes this quite
incredible claim,
what first you will completely
reject, that the most efficient
organization is the bureaucracy.
Right?
That's exactly the opposite
what you think.
When something is very
inefficient, then you say,
"Well this is so
bureaucratic."
Right?
Weber nevertheless claims that
the most efficient organization
is bureaucracy.
Then the question is how is
bureaucracy related to
capitalism and socialism?
Is really capitalism a
bureaucratic organization?
What is the relationship
between capitalist market
economy and bureaucracy?
What are the consequences of
bureaucracy?
And also then some
contradiction of
bureaucratization.
Now let's just quickly rush
through what are the
characteristics of a
bureaucracy.
Well, he said,
"the purest type of legal
authority"--
this is, as I said,
counterintuitive--
"is that one which employs
a bureaucratic administrative
staff."
And well what are the
characteristics of this staff in
order to qualify to bureaucracy?
Well they have to be personally
free.
So it cannot be
clients--right?--of a mentor.
Right?
They are legally free
individuals.
That makes it so
different--right?--from a
traditional organization.
That's why a family is not a
bureaucratic organization,
because you are not there by
choice.
Right?
And then a bureaucracy is
organized into a hierarchy of
offices--
this is something which
basically we already covered--
and the offices are filled by a
free contract,
and in this contract what your
qualification is,
that's what we
call--right?--meritocracy.
People do have a certain
degree, and that degree
qualifies them to be incumbents
of a certain office.
And they receive a fixed salary.
It's not quite a bureaucratic
organization if you are working
for a commission.
Right?
You are really in a
bureaucratic organization when
you sign a contract and you know
exactly what your fringe
benefits will be and what your
annual salary will be.
Typically the office is the
sole occupation of the
incumbents, and it constitutes a
career.
This is also very important;
again, very different from a
traditional organization where
people could actually be
incumbents of a number of
positions and could draw,
in fact, even incomes from a
number of positions.
In a pure bureaucratic
organization,
you really can have only a
single occupation.
If, for instance,
somebody is appointed with
tenure to Yale,
and is coming from another
institution,
he'll have to resign from his
or her tenure at the other
institution.
If you are employed by Yale,
you can be only a Yale
employee;
you cannot hold multiple jobs
at the same time.
And it constitutes a career.
The career means there is a
ladder.
You have some sense how you
will progress in this
bureaucratic hierarchy.
Again, universities are
classical bureaucracies--that
you enter as an assistant
professor;
then you are,
seven to nine years,
depending on the institution,
without tenure;
then you are being promoted to
tenure;
then you expect at one point of
time to become a full professor;
blah-blah-blah. Right?
This is what it meant,
it is a career.
And in many bureaucratic
organizations,
even in the business
world--right?--you have a sense
how you progress.
In a law firm--right?--if you
enter a law firm--right?--you
have a pretty clear idea;
it's actually very similar to
the universities.
Usually for seven years you are
working for the law firm,
and that's when you can
become--right?--a partner in the
law firm.
Right?
So you have a sense how your
career will unfold.
Well this is something we
already kind of covered--
right?--that you are separated
from the means of
administration,
because you are subjected to
discipline and control.
Now comes the very
controversial idea,
and that we have to talk about
it.
Weber's claim,
which is very much against
commonsense,
that the purely bureaucratic
type of administration is
capable of attaining the highest
degree of efficiency.
Well let me,
on the other hand,
from this citation,
underline an important point
here.
And this is--of course Weber
was talking about a very
specific type of organization,
bureaucracies,
which were, relatively
speaking,
historically quite
efficient--right?--
the Prussian type of
bureaucracy.
But here he emphasizes--and
these are two very important
words--"from the technical
point of view."
Right?
The bureaucracy,
from the technical point of
view, is the most efficient
organization.
It does not necessarily mean
that it does achieve the highest
welfare for people who are
seeking to navigate in a
bureaucratic organization.
But technically speaking,
it is the most efficient.
Why?
Because it has a very high
degree of predictability.
I mean, this predictability
might suggest that it will take
you a long time to get through
of that bloody red tape--
right?--what the bureaucracy
imposes on you.
But you know exactly the red
tape, and you know,
if you are stuck,
how to try to appeal and to get
the process moving.
And therefore the crucial issue
he said, why the bureaucracy is
so efficient,
because it is technically
competent and it is predictable.
And this is what makes it
actually so--to fit so well with
a market.
Well he said,
"And what else?"
If it is not bureaucracy,
how can you otherwise organize
an organization?
If it is not done
bureaucratically,
then it is dilettantism.
Right?
And you may want to think about
this.
Now here comes the question
about how does bureaucracy and
capitalism fits into?
And now he makes a very
intriguing, very provocative
claim.
I think it is very deep,
and deserves your attention.
He said, "The primary
source of superiority in a
bureaucratic administration lies
in technical knowledge."
Right?
Bureaucracy is domination
through knowledge.
Well, a very provocative,
very important claim.
Right?
Bureaucracy is--right?--the par
excellence meritocratic
organization--
right?--where people who are
issuing command are issuing
command with the assumptions
that they are the most competent
people to carry this out.
Well whether this is the case
or not--you remember,
Weber is always operating with
ideal types, or pure types.
The concrete cases may be
different from it.
You may have people who are not
competent to exercise the
authority, what they do
exercise.
But I think it is important
that you have the ideal type,
because then you can be upset,
and you say,
"These bloody
bastards."
Right?
"It is incompetent;
cannot do the job."
And then you can appeal and to
say,
"Why don't you remove this
person,
because this person does not
know what his or her job
is?"
And actually such appeal very
often is consequential.
People occasionally are removed
their position if their
incompetence is being
demonstrated.
Well this is very difficult to
do at a university,
because universities,
we have this system of tenure.
You know?
After you've suffered for seven
years as an assistant professor,
you are promoted to tenure,
and then it is very difficult
to get you out of the job.
But even at the university this
is possible.
If you find out that I'm
completely incompetent--
right?--you document that I am
incompetent--
right?--that I am just
misinterpreting all the authors
you had here.
And then you can
appeal--right?--to the
university, and you can say that
I really should be removed;
my tenure should be invoked.
And if I'm found to be
incompetent, I will lose my job;
but the only way to do it,
is through my incompetence.
But actually universities very
rarely do it,
because it's a very painful
exercise.
But because they are
bureaucracies there
is--right?--the rule that it can
happen, and it should happen in
these cases.
And then he said,
"Well from this point of
view,
it really does not matter
whether an economy is organized
as a capitalistic economy,
based on private ownership,
or whether it is organized as a
socialist economy,
based on public
ownership."
Right?
And, in fact,
now he goes even further;
and it's very interesting what
he's got to say here.
He's writing somewhere in
1919,1920.
The Soviet Union already
exists, Soviet Russia already
exists.
There is already a society
which calls itself socialist,
which eliminated private
ownership.
And he said,
"Well socialism would
require a still higher degree of
formal bureaucratization than
capitalism."
That's a very interesting idea.
Though until now he
suggested--right?--
that the bureaucratic
organization fits the best with
free market economy,
now he said actually socialism
will be even more bureaucratic.
And then I think what comes
very--it's a very intriguing
idea,
and he said,
"But the big problem with
socialism is that there will be
a big conflict here between the
formal rationality and
substantive rationality,
what the bureaucracy carries
out."
And you know by now--right?--or
you have at least a hunch what
he's getting at between formal
and substantive rationality.
Right?
Formal rationality is that you
are simply implementing the
rules of the game.
Substantive rationality is you
are actually concerned with the
welfare, the substantive goals
of the action.
And he said,
"Well, if you have a
publicly owned economy,
centrally planned economy,
then the central planners make
substantive decisions about the
economy."
They decide,
for instance,
where government or taxpayer
money should go to--which
branches of the economy should
be investment going to.
Right?
In a capitalist economy,
governments typically cannot do
that.
Right?
They set the rules of the game.
Well the best--they manage
interest rates and they may be
able to manage the currency
exchange rate,
but they cannot allocate
resources across the economy.
Of if they do,
then people will say,
"We are on the road to
socialism."
Right?
To the extent substantive
rationality is involved.
But he said,
"Well if it is socialism,
there will be this big
tension."
Right?
You cannot be at the same time
formally rational and
substantively rational.
You either consider the content
of your decisions,
or you are concerned simply
with the procedures of the
decision.
If you are concerned with the
procedure, that is formal
rationality.
If you are concerned with the
content, that is substantive
rationality.
Let me just give you one
example about the legal system.
Indeed, in Communist
societies--and probably to some
extent even China today,
much less so than it was let's
say thirty of forty years ago--
well when justice is being
served by the court,
the court is not blind to who
the people who are being accused
of committing some crime is.
The communist legal system
called itself a class law;
that, in fact,
the purpose of the legal system
is not to be blind--right?--who
committed the crime.
The purpose of the legal system
is--that was the kind of
legitimacy claim under
Communism--to defend the
interests of the working class.
Right?
And therefore that was
specifically a legal system
based on substantive
rationality.
Right?
Well capitalist legal systems
tend to be procedurally--ri
ght?--rationalistic,
formally rationalistic.
In principle it doesn't matter
who the person is when you are
serving justice.
This is again the ideal. Right?
In concrete cases actually
judges might consider some
substantive characteristics of
the person who is on trial,
not simply to implement the
law.
May consider as mitigating
circumstances--right?--for
instance, when they are passing
the law.
And, of course,
there are other reasons how
actually substantive
considerations enter the game.
You know?
If you are white and rich,
you can hire a better defense
lawyer and your chances to get
off the hook within the same
rules are better.
So substantive considerations
enter the thing.
But that's the exception;
that's not supposed to happen.
We are angry when this happens.
Right?
We want to have a faceless
legal system.
Right?
Justice is blind. Right?
This blindness of justice
means--right?--this is simply
procedurally just--right?--and
not substantively so.
Right?
This is why justice is shown
with blind eyes.
Now what are the consequences
of bureaucratization?
Here are some of them.
He said there is a tendency of
leveling of interest;
since everybody is in principle
equal before the law and
therefore interest will be
leveled.
You are not supposed to take
into account people's position
in it.
Well there is a
tendency--meritocratic
tendency--that people higher up
will have higher levels of
training, or more training,
as such.
And--this is again justice is
blind--
what is important is that the
essence of a bureaucracy has to
be a formalistic impersonality:
sine ira et studio,
without hatred and passion.
Right?
This is why occasionally you
are kind of upset when you are
confronted with the bureaucracy.
You have a special problem--you
know?--
and then the bureaucracy tends
to be insensitive to your
special problem--
right?--,when it is a real
bureaucracy.
Right?
You can say,
"I just had a fight with
my partner and this is why I
cannot take the test."
Well, sine ira et studio.
I mean, in a real bureaucratic,
discussion leader or professor
will say, "Too bad.
This is your personal business.
The test is right now."
Right?
"You take it or leave
it."
Well, I mean,
we are usually not that stupid
bureaucrats.
But that's the spirit of
bureaucracy.
Right?
Without hatred and passion;
that also means that you are
not motivated by personal
feelings.
You don't differentiate this is
a person I like and then I give
preferences;
or dislike, and therefore give
a worse grade.
All right, there are a number
of contradictions of
bureaucracy.
It is very formalistic.
And he said there is also
another interesting tendency.
Though it is formalistic and
it's supposed to go simply by
the rules,
occasionally,
not only under socialism,
in all systems the bureaucracy
tends to have some sensitivity
to substantive rationality,
to the welfare of the people
who are under the bureaucracy.
And then it can be turned into
a clientalistic system;
the bureaucracy can have these
tendencies.
And think about welfare
bureaucracies--right?--which do
have a great deal of
clientalistic tendencies built
into them.
Well, and there are these
various limitations of
bureaucratic authority.
One is collegiality,
division of powers,
and representation.
Well I don't want to dwell too
long on the notion of
collegiality.
Collegiality,
he says, really grows out of
what we knew as professional
groups or professional
organizations.
There are different ways how
collegiality can operate.
One way--that means that you
are interacting with other
people in the same organization,
on the basis of collegiality.
You can get a good sense of
this collegiality;
for instance,
it's very important in the
medical profession.
If you go to a doctor for a
second opinion,
this doctor is really not
supposed to say that his or her
colleague,
the other doctor,
really screwed it and he gave
you the wrong diagnosis or the
wrong therapy.
Right?
Collegiality means that you
stick together--right?--that the
profession sticks together.
There is a very strong sense of
collegiality among lawyers,
or at least supposed to be.
The ethic of the legal
profession is very much
collegiality.
And it is also incidentally in
the universities.
I mean, faculty is not supposed
to badmouth each other.
Right?
They certainly,
towards students,
they have to show that they
have a collegial relationship
with each other.
Mutual respect binds them
together.
Occasionally there is what he
calls veto collegiality;
the collegiality does give veto
right to certain people to run
this organization.
A single person can veto a
decision, as such.
Again, very typical in
universities when it comes,
for instance,
to a decision whether somebody
will be granted a permanent
position in a university;
so-called tenure,
there is actually--the
president of the university
usually has a veto right and can
veto.
No matter that all bodies
approved that,
the president usually has a
veto right--can veto that
decision.
It uses it very rarely,
but occasionally it does use
its veto right.
So even in a collegially
organized bureaucracy,
there is these individual veto
rights;
otherwise, collegiality usually
operates through the different
committees and advisory boards.
I mean, collegiality usually is
emerging in a situation where
you have a common trade or a
common profession.
That's when a group is being
organized as a collegial
bureaucracy, as such.
And many of you will end up in
professions in which you will
have such a collegial
environment, as such.
Okay.
The other issue is--which is
also a limitation of the
functioning of the bureaucracy--
right?--collegiality
meant--right?--
that though the bureaucracy is
supposed to be blind to
individual differences,
it's not always,
because we have loyalties
towards each other,
based on our profession.
Lawyers are loyal to lawyers,
and doctors are loyal to fellow
doctors, and professors have a
degree of loyalty.
Now the other one is division
of powers.
Well this division of powers,
what Locke and Montesquieu and
Rousseau were talking about,
well it's a functional
system--he cites Montesquieu
about the separation of power--
and that creates some degree of
unpredictability in the system;
but necessary,
but creates some degree of
unpredictability.
Nevertheless,
this is the way how to prevent
tyranny.
So therefore it is good for the
economy;
by what he means for the market
economy.
And then comes the question of
representations,
and different forms of
representations.
Well there are--again,
representations can be
democratic, but is not
necessarily all that bloody
democratic.
In fact, there is a possibility
of representation when the
representation is happening
through some hereditary means.
Traditional authority;
people who were born in certain
positions,
like Montesquieu himself,
was supposed to represent
certain interests,
which is beyond the personal
interests of the person--
right?;
was supposed to represent the
interests of the whole estate,
what it was standing for.
Well it's also--in modern times
we do have a representation
where representations can be
selected by rotation or lot--
in Ancient Greece this
happened--and there can be a
limited mandate;
they are not representing
necessarily the interest of the
constituency and they can be
recalled.
This was typical of Communist
bureaucracies.
Or there can be what he calls
free representation--
it's what we would associate to
democracy--
where the representative is
elected,
rather than selected or
appointed.
But it is also not bound by
instructions;
is only obliged to express his
own conviction.
So this is what we have seen in
the Congress happening.
Right?
That Democrats voted with
Republicans, because those
Democrats argued,
"I'm not under party
discipline."
Right?
"I am acting out of my
conscience."
Well a couple of ideas about
free representation,
and how it goes with a
capitalist economy.
Well what is
crucial--right?--and Weber keeps
coming back and back to this--
what is vital for a capitalist
economy is to be calculability
and reliability.
And well in early stages,
in fact, there was property
qualification,
who could actually vote,
and that was implemented in
order to make the system more
predictable for the propertied
classes.
There was a great deal of
concern by the bourgeoisie to
give universal suffrage,
because they felt then this
will be unpredictable,
who will win the elections.
In fact, very often,
these were monarchs and
absolutist monarchs,
who were pushing for
extension--right?--
of suffrage,
because they wanted to use this
against the propertied
bourgeoisie.
That's again something very
counterintuitive,
but I think historically a very
accurate understanding.
Right?
So one has to be very careful
what exactly the relationship
with a capitalist economic order
and democracy is.
Well so Weber's fundamental
argument is what many people who
do the history of the democratic
movement will agree;
others will disagree with him.
Again, a good subject for
discussion.
Parliamentary free
representation was the product
between struggles;
actually struggles between
monarchs and the bourgeoisie.
Well I think I'll just leave
this here.
I probably gave us enough food
for the discussion.
Thank you.